gwen is showing off her bridal look
my god who wouldn't want to be married
to gwen stefani and
e.t has new details about how she and
blake said i do
over the weekend i have so many rings
picked out
the couple tied the knot on july 3 in an
intimate ceremony surrounded by family
which took place on blake's ranch in
oklahoma
on monday the marriage became instagram
official with gwen posting
this looped video of the bride getting
her veil into position
she tagged blake in the post adding a
heart and a prayer emoji
next his name we are just having the
time of our lives and we never expected
that this late in our lives so
we're just trying to save her every
every moment together blake and gwen's
happy day caps off
years of wedding speculation as their
fans have been dying to know
when the big day would finally arrive is
it still girlfriend today i just want to
double i
read the magazines this morning the
couple began dating in 2015
and they got engaged in october of last
year you know
she's never not been supportive or a
cheerleader or just
uh just the most encouraging
person i've ever had in my life after
blake popped the question
gwen posted this sparkly pic of her
engagement ring to instagram
she wrote yes please how would you say
gwen makes you a better man
oh my god i don't i can't remember i
don't want to remember
what i was like before gwen actually if
that answers your question
blake was one of the original judges on
the voice upon its debut
in 2011 with gwen securing a judge's
chair of her own
three years later for season seven you
know he's like my bestie
so at this point in our relationship
we're always looking for
what's the next thing that we haven't
accomplished yet
the location for blake and gwen's
nuptials are special for many reasons
as blake told et he spent quality time
with gwen's entire family at the
oklahoma estate
i see you guys come down here all the
time with the boys it's gotta be cool to
have this
awesome community to come to with them
how much fun has that been for you
it's been it's been great and it's uh
it's been a lot of fun for me
to to be the one to get to expose them
to
this out in the country basically you
know
and they they love it so much her entire
family and when i say her family i mean
all i'm talking about the kids the mom
the dad the brother
uh you know it's just you know there's
times when we've had
like holiday gatherings and i'm talking
about 30 plus
family members from from herself from
her side from my side
it's uh it's we have so much fun i don't
think he should be able to
to have that much fun it's probably not
legal in california
[Music]